la séance est
ouverte madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers collègues dans la nuit
du 18 au 19 novembre à crépul dans la
Drome en pleine fête de village est
survenu un drame qui uil et choque notre
pays tout entier plongeant chacun
d'entre nous dans une infinie
tristesse Thomas 16 ans a été poignardé
à
mort 16 autres personnes ont été
blessées à l'arme blanche dont trois
grièvement un déchaînement de violence a
fait basculer une commune française dans
l'horreur et je veux dire au nom de la
représentation nationale toute notre
solidarité de cœur et d'esprit devant
cette
tragédie je veux saluer la dignité et la
gravité de la Marche Blanche
qui a salué la mémoire de Thomas il
importe que justice soit rendue et la
justice n'est ni la vengeance ni la
vindicte pour Thomas en signe de
solidarité avec ses parents sa famille
ses amis ses proches je vous demande
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés de bien vouloir observer une
minute de
silence
je vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci Madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés comme je l'ai fait au Sénat la
semaine dernière je veux à mon tour
adresser mes condoléances et dire ma
peine aux parents aux proches à tous les
habitants de Crépol après la mort de
Thomas Thomas avait 16 ans il incarnait
des valeurs de générosité et de courage
si propre à son sport le rugby il avait
une vie remplie d'espoir et de promesses
devant lui j'ai également une pensée
pour les personnes blessées dont
certaines
grièvement je remercie enfin la mère de
crépool Madame Martine lagu dont
l'engagement est
remarquable hier le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier verérrant s'est
rendu sur place il a pu échanger avec la
famille avec les habitants avec les
élus la mort de Thomas est un drame qui
a touché et ému la France c'est une
démonstration de violence extrêmement
choquante toute la lumière devrait être
faite neu personnes ont déjà été
interpellées et mises en examen j'ai
toute confiance dans les enquêteurs et
les
magistrats c'est grâce à eux et à eux
seuls que la justice
passera certains individus violents
rendent impossible le quotidien vient de
nos quartiers de nos villes et de nos
villages c'est
inacceptable je veux le dire aux parents
de Thomas le dire à tous les Français
avec mon gouvernement nous serons
intraitables j'ai annoncé récemment un
projet de loi sur la justice des mineurs
pour davantage responsabiliser les
parents et mieux sanctionner les
jeunes face à la désinhibition de la
violence chez certains il nous faut de
nouvelles réponses j'ai demander aux
ministres Gérald daranin et Éric Dupont
Moretti de me faire des propositions
pour lutter efficacement face à ces
bandes et les empêcher de nuire nous
devons tout faire pour qu'un tel drame
ne se reproduise pas mesdames et
messieurs les députés dans un tel moment
nous avons un devoir
d'unité un devoir de dignité sans pour
autant minimiser les faits un devoir de
dessessence en respectant le deuil de la
famille et des proches sans récupération
politique sans attiser les
haines je condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté les démonstrations et les actes
de violence de l'ultr drroite ces
derniers jours la justice ne vient
jamais de la violence nous ne laisserons
rien
passer
mesdames et messieurs les députés toute
la lumière doit être faite sur la mort
de Thomas et nous y veillerons et vous
pouvez compter sur moi et mon
gouvernement pour lutter avec force et
détermination contre les violences je
merci merci beaucoup madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre
je vous remercie l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au Gouvernement et je suis
heureuse en votre nom de souhaiter la
bienvenue à deux délégations l'une du
Parlement de la République de Moldavie
conduite par Madame Marcella Adam
président du groupe d'amitié moldavie-
France
et l'autre du Parlement fédéral du
Royaume de Belgique conduite par
Monsieur
Bert lacher président de la section
bilatérale
belgiquefance merci beaucoup donc la
première question va être posée par
Monsieur Henri Alfandari pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre les connaissances
les connaissances des jeunes entrant en
4e en 2023 ont fait l'objet d'une
évaluation nationale portant sur 739
établissements et 795000 collégiens
celle-ci montre un effondrement sans
précédent de leur niveau cela fait dire
à nombre de nos concitoyens que la
France est entrée dans une r ession
éducative continue qui risque de faire
de nous une nation dilétr si tel est le
cas que va-t-il advevenir de not
démocratie nous sommes à quelques jours
de la publication des résultats
internationaux PISA sur l'évaluation de
la performance des systèmes éducatifs et
nombre d'observateurs s'inquièteent de
la place de la France dans ce classement
le système éducatif a vu se développer
des ramifications toujours plus
nombreuses dans les programmes scolaire
le développement des enfants doit être
pensé de manière globale cependant nous
ne pouvons laisser nos enseignants
devant des injonctions contradictoires
si nous admettons que le français et les
mathématiques sont des savoirs
fondamentaux prioritaires nous ne
pouvons continuer à refuser de
hiérarchiser nos enseignements si chaque
élève ne dispose pas des compétences
fondamentales en matière de français de
mathématique et de lecture il est à
craindre que l'ensemble des efforts sur
les temps scolaires et périscolaires ne
soit voué à l'échec le défi de notre
société comme santé et ailleurs et notre
capacité à former plus rapidement
qualitativement et tout au long de la
vie professionnelle vous avez annoncé un
effort de votre ministère en matière de
formation des enseignants considérant à
juste titre que cette formation devait
être hors temps scolaire monsieur le
ministre quelle disposition concrète
prévoyez-vous pour accompagner le
développement professionnel des
enseignants afin de permettre à notre
nation de retrouver la place qui devrait
être la sienne en matière
d'apprentissage et de maîtrise des
fondamentaux
scolaires je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
alfandar depuis
1987 mon ministère le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale fait passer la
même dictée à un panel représentatif des
élèves de CM2 en 1987 il y avait en
moyenne 10 fautes nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 20 fautes en moyenne en
1987 il n'y avait que 6 % des élèves qui
faisaient plus de 25 fautes nous sommes
aujourd'hui à près de 30 % en 1987 il y
avait près de 15 % des élèves qui
faisaient moins de deux fautes nous
sommes à peine à plus de 1 % aujourd'hui
oui il y a une baisse du niveau il faut
la regarder sans phare il faut le dire
et surtout il faut y répondre le point
positif des évaluations qui ont été
rendues à la rentrer c'est qu'on voit
qu'un investissement massif et des choix
politiques permettent d'inverser une
tendance la réalité c'est que le niveau
des élèves qui rentrent en 6e cette
année s'améliore par rapport au niveau
des élèves qui entrai en 6e en 2017 très
concrètement on voit que sur le français
et les mathématiques il y a une
amélioration du niveau parce qu'on a
réinvesti massivement est-ce que c'est
suffisant non il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin et vous l'avez vu j'ai ouvert
un certain nombre de chantiers j'aurai
l'occasion de faire des annonces la
semaine prochaine j'assume de le dire
laisser passer au collège un élève qui
ne sait ni lire ni écrire ni compter
cela relève d'une forme de
maltraitance laisser entrer au lycée un
élève qui accumule un tel retard ça
n'est pas possible j'aurai l'occasion
d'annoncer des mesures fortes sur le
sujet dès la semaine prochaine pour cela
j'ai beaucoup échangé avec l'ensemble
des acteurs éducatifs je veux saluer le
travail qui est conduit à l'Assemblée
nationale par Annie jeunevar et Fabrice
le vigoureux dans la mission qu'il
réalise sur la question de la lecture
oui nous devons nous interroger j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire sur sur la place
du redoublement sur des groupes de
niveau au collège pour permettre enfin
de faire progresser tout le monde sur le
soutien qui apporté à nos enseignants je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour annoncer mon plan
d'élévation du niveau général nous le
devons à nos élèves et nous le devons à
notre pays merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Victor
Cateau pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre après l'injuste et inutile
réforme des retraites menées par votre
gouvernement vous avez décidé dans un
mépris qui n' dégale que votre
déconnexion à la réalité de continuer à
détrousser les Français votre Ministre
de l'économie Monsieur Bruno Le Maire a
ainsi directement insulté les Français
en les exhortant à se secouer les puces
une sortie digne des phrases du
président de la République qu'il espère
sans doute remplacer en 2027 mais loin
de lui suffire il a décidé de s'attaquer
à nos seiors au piliers de notre société
en envisageant de réduire la durée de
leur allocation chômage votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
écrase les Français sous le poids de son
mépris les réduisant à une peine
quotidienne là je ne devrais pas être un
fardeau madame la Première ministre
apprenez madame qu'être au chômage passé
55 ans n'est pas un choix de vie mais
une contrainte imposée par les
circonstances dont vous êtes les
responsables les seiors ne se compèent
pas dans une retraite forcée et
prématurée dans une France où il faut
désormais choisir entre manger et
s'habiller je vous laisserai madame la
Première ministre allez expliquer votre
nouvelle lubie au français aux habitants
de ma circonscription comme à corantan
58 ans habitant d'Aline les marais qui
recherche désespérément un emploi depuis
avril 2022 qui fait tout pour s'en
sortir et qui s'inquiète de l'avenir
s'il ne parvient pas à trouver un emploi
votre devoir madame la Première ministre
est de prendre des mesures pour résoudre
ces problèmes et non de plonger ces
personnes dans un désespoir encore plus
profond ma question est donc la suivante
quand allez-vous mettre fin à cette
oppression systématique des travilleurs
français quand allez-vous écou écouter
et répondre à leurs préoccupations
légitimes et surtout quand allez-vous
enfin revenir à la
réalité je vous remercie la parole est à
madame Carole grandjan ministre chargée
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député câ rappelons
peut-être déjà le contexte dans lequel
ces discussions interviennent vous le
savez probablement le 10 novembre
dernier les partenaires sociaux ont
conclu un accord sur l'assurance chômage
accord qui s'inscrit dans une dynamique
de réforme engagée depuis 2019 et qui
nous amemène à réfléchir sur les
conditions d'indemnisation du chômage et
notamment sur la modulation de la durée
d'indemnisation selon l'état de la
conjoncture du marché du travail cet
accord il ne prévoit pas de dispositions
spécifiques pour les situations liées à
la seniorité or on voit bien
effectivement qu'au-delà des principes
qui qui ont été déjà dégagé dans cet
accord au-delà du montant des économies
visées il y a des enjeux à mettre des
règles autour de la seiorité sur
l'assurance chômage c'est au fond ce qui
est aujourd'hui à discuter dans le cadre
des concertation sociale à venir sur les
seniors notamment et pour voir dans
cette période complexe qu'on le sait
qu'on sait fragile pour nos concitoyens
comment est-ce que nous mettons des
modalités spécifiques d'indemnisation du
chômage des seniors qui doivent tenir en
compte de la réforme des retraites et du
report de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
donc vous le savez cette question va
être réouverte avec les partenaires
sociaux qui vont engager cette
négociation sur les seniors et il sera
donc temps de voir comment nous
accompagnons les seniors dans l'emploi
et pour la fin de leur parcours
professionnel c'est un débat monsieur le
le député un débat qui viendra d'abord
par les partenaires sociaux et que nous
aurons bien sûr ici dans l'hémicycle
dans un second temps je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le député merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre si en 2
minutes il fallait résumer
l'incompétence l'impuissance et
l'incapacité de votre gouvernement à
réagir au problèmes des Français vous
venez de le démontrer parfaitement et
alors je j'ai une chose à vous rajouter
madame la ministre vivement
2027 je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame soumien bouroua pour le groupe
GDR merci madame la Présidente notre
groupe s'associe à l'image rendue au
jeunes Thomas suite aux violences
imputées à l'extrême droite à Dublin le
Premier ministre irlandais a dénoncé les
émetiers en déclarant qu'il faisait
honte à Dublin honte à l'Irlande nous
aurions aimé entendre la même
indignation de la part du gouvernement
face au défilé dans plusieurs villes de
miliciens d'extrême droite cherchant à
casser des noirs et des Arabes ces
démonstrations de force qui fracture la
société française angoisse nos
concitoyens qui doutent de la volonté
politique à défendre le vivre ensemble
désormais une partie de la classe
politique ne condamne même plus ces
actes abjects pire certains soufflent
sur les braises en participant au climat
nosé àond qui règne dans notre pays et
qui est repris en boucle sur les chaînes
d'info en continu cela fait maintenant
plusieurs années que nous dénonçons le
tapis rouge qui est déroulé à l'extrême
droite et à son idéologie raciste
xénophobe et antisémite les conséquences
de ces discours de haine sont en train
de nous exploser au visage lentement ils
détruisent les valeurs humanistes et
solidaires qui constituent les
fondements de notre République de plus
en plus
fracturé il y a urgence à agir il faut
tout mettre en œuvre pour rétablir le
lien sociale répondre au aux inquiétudes
des Français qui sont la crise
alimentaire la crise du logement les
enjeux climatiques
l'insécurité notre République est en
danger nous sommes face à un tournant
qui appelle des politiques fortes et
courageuse éloigné de celle que vous
prenez aujourd'hui le projet de Loi de
l'immigration en est en est un de ces
révélateur d'un anilement politique qui
est dangereux avec l'extrême droite
es-vousci beau mettre fin à ce poison
lent merci beaucoup madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
m madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame les député
vous avez parfaitement raison ce qui
s'est passé à roman suriser ou à Lyon
dans d'autres lieux de France est
absolument scandaleux et en en effet
mérite une condamnation morale politique
la plus forte celle de milice d'extrême
droite qui sont venus en tout cas pour
ce qui roman sur riser puisque c'est
documenté
venu en effet comme vous l'avez très
bien dit des mots aussi difficile taper
des Noirs taper des arabes pour mettre
fin à ce qu'il pensent être au grand
remplacement pourendre leur mot nosé à
bon je voudrais ici saluer le travail du
renseignement territorial roman sur
riser a permis de documenter puisque ces
personnes ont pu être suivies ont permis
d'intervenir avant que cela
n'intervienne et connaître un scénario à
l'irlandaise comme vous l'avez vous-même
évoqué et a permet de très nombreuses
interpellations qui dans les heures
qu'on suivi ont pu grâce au service de
Monsieur gardesso être montré en
comparion immédiate avec des
condamnations qui sont extrêmement
fermes salueer également ce qu'a fait la
préfecture les policiers des gendarmes à
Lyon au de nombreuses interpellations
ont lieu hier suite à une manifestation
sauvage de militants d'ultra droite
d'extrême droite qui porta des discours
fascistes des discours racistes des
discours inacceptables et nous aussi
madame la députée nous voulons le dire
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi il n'y a
pas condamnation unanime de ceux qui
veulent remplacer le droit par la force
de ceux qui veulent faire par des
milices le travail des policiers et des
gendarmes et de cules qui veulent faire
imaginer dire et répéter qu'il y aurait
une race je m des guillets supérieur à
d'autres je peux vous assurer madame la
députée qu'à la demande de la première
ministre et du président de la publ des
moyens nombreux sont mis pour suivre les
1500 personnes radicalisées de
l'ultraadroite pour pouvoir les
interpeller pour engager les procédure
de disolution comme je l'ai fait avec
Génération identitaire comme je le ferai
demain avec la division Martel qui sera
présentée au prochain conseil des
ministres et deux autres groupuscules
d'extrême droite connaissent aujourd'hui
des contradictoires qui permettront je
l'espère aprèsdemain d'être dissous
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur pour
le groupe
Renaissance madame la
présidente madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Gérald daranin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outrmèes monsieur le ministre
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche un
homme de 55 ans a été tué par des coups
de feu qui ciblaient le bâtiment de son
domicile rue blanquy à Dijon il est mort
pendant son sommeil c'est une nouvelle
victime collatérale d'un règlement de
compte dans une affaire de trafic de
stupéfiants je je suis rendu sur place
avec mon collègue Philippe Fray pour
constater les fait et recueillir le
sentiment des habitants du quartier ils
sont choqués terrorisé et désemparé la
drogue est un cancer un cancer qui ronge
notre pays elle tue des innocents
détruit la santé des consommateurs
vampirise des mineurs apatés par le gain
engraresse des trafiquants qui font
régner leur lois dans les quartiers dans
les rues dans les cages d'escalier ils
pourrissent la vie à des milliers de
Français la drogue finance des réseaux
criminels la prtitution les ventes
d'armes qui portent atteinte à la
sécurité de nos concitoyens monsieur le
ministre je connais votre engagement et
celui du gouvernement dans la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue et les bons
résultats que les forces de l'ordre et
les douanes ont présenté en mars dernier
malgré les moyens importants alloué à la
justice malgré l'augmentation des
effectifs de forces de l'ordre dont la
métropole de Dijon a pu bénéficier 50
policiers supplémentair depuis 2020 le
sentiment d'insécurité l'insécurité
persiste et les habitants des quartiers
ne perçoivent pas concrètement dans leur
quotidien le fruit de cet investissement
pas de liberté véritable sans la
sécurité disait Thomas HS le fléo de la
drogue doit être enrayé au plus vite
monsieur le ministre comment peut-on
davantage associer les collectivités les
bailleurs et les locaux et les élus
locaux dans cette lutte prioritaire
comment redonner monsieur le ministre de
l'espoir aux habitants qui aspirent
légitimement à vivre en paix je vous
remercie merci je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs députés monsieur le député
Borda je voudraisabord évidemment avoir
une pensée pour cette famille qui a
perdu un homme de 55 ans qui dans son
sommeil a connu la mort par ceux qui
utilisent des armes pour faire la
marchandise de la mort comme vous l'avez
très bien dit ce point de deal à Dijon
et vous le savez très harcelé par les
services de police et de gendarmerie et
les règlements de compte sont parfois la
conséquence extrêmement malheureuse du
travail de la justice et de la police et
en effet les moyens extrêmement
importants que nous mettons dans
l'agglomération d'jeunesse le préfet a
eu l'occasion de le redire et avec tous
les élus vous avez l'occasion de le
constater montre que nous portons des
coups très durs contre la drogue et
lorsque ces coups sont menés une
bataille de territoire né et nous devons
absolument la condamner et c'est pour
cela que j'ai décidé d'octroyer des
moyens encore sulémentaire à Dijon et
lutter comme nous le faisons à
villeorbane à voovelin et anim vous avez
vu qu'il y a 3 mois des faits divers
similaires ont eu lieu 30
interpellations à nî 2 mois plus tard 15
interpellations à villeorbane vingtaine
à voau envelin et des démantellements
complets de trafiquants des points deal
qui n'existent plus et des trafiquants
qui sont présentés devant les services
du garde des saut pour je l'espère comme
vous des condamnations exemplaires pour
lutter contre la drogue il faut des
moyens nous en avons il faut une volonté
nous l'avons il faut aussi la fin de la
consommation par les personnes car s'il
n'y avait pas de consommateur monsieur
le député il n'y aurait pas de dur et il
faut tenir contre la drogue partout le
même discours celui que les
consommateurs font naître les trafics et
nous devons être intraatable contre ces
consommateurs en même temps que contre
ces dealers qui financent le terrorisme
qui finance proxénétisme et les discours
que nous entendons qui à la fois
condamnent les morts de règlement de
compte tout en autorisation une sorte de
débat sur la consommation du cannabis de
la cocaïne c'est évidemment inacceptable
nous lutterons jour et nuit contre la
drogue qui malheureusement gangraine nos
quartiers merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pancher pour le groupe lot
madame madame la Première ministre nous
entamons l'examen de la loi contrôle de
l'immigration et renforcement de
l'intégration je veux dire ici que
lorsque l'on parle de migrant il s'agit
d'être humain un migrant c'est un homme
un migrant c'est une femme un migrant
c'est un enfant quêtre français c'est
connaître notre histoire que notre pays
s'est construit par vague d'immigration
successive mon grand-père Louis rebuszi
était italien d'origine cette
particularité je la partage avec Eric
soioti et Jordane Bardella notamment je
connais cette histoire le mépris les
rejets et la bêtise humaine un rapport
du préfet du Nord au début du siècle
dernier expliquait que les Italiens
vivaient toujours ensemble ne parlai pas
le français sentaiit mauvais et il
concluaient qu'ils étaient
inassimilables mon grand-père a combattu
à Verdin et deux de ses frères sont
morts pour la France être français c'est
défendre les valeurs de la République
c'est faire vivre la sa devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité sur la loi
immigration elle doit nous permettre
d'être plus efficace et plus juste à
liyotte nous sommes pour le réalisme
nous ne voulons ni angélisme ni
extrémisme la question de l'aide médical
d'État qui permet aux étrangers en
situation irrégulière de se soigner sous
certaines conditions doit être étudié
par ce prisme les sénateurs ont voté sa
suppression or en 2012 l'Espagne avait
pris la même décision avant de revenir
dessus car cela avait entraîné une
hausse des cûts et 15 % de la mortalité
des personnes concernées 10000
professionnels de nous alerte revenir
sur laame serait catastrophique
engorgerait les urgences or nous
connaissons déjà le triste état de nos
service de santé supprimer la me c'est
donc prendre un grand risque pour la
santé de tous nos compatriotes quelle
est la position précise de votre
gouvernement sur cette question elle est
importante madame merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
mesames et monsieurs les députés
monsieur le président Bertrand Pancher
alors comme vous l'avez dit l'examen du
projet de loi immigration porté par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald haranin a
commencé hier en commission ce projet de
loi répond à une préoccupation de nos
concitoyens et il vise à relever un
double défi éloigner plus efficacement
ceux qui n'ont pas le droit de rester en
France et mieux intégrer ce que nous
choisissons d'accueillir monsieur le
Président Pancher je suis certaine que
nous pouvons nous retrouver autour de
ces objectifs avec les parlementaires de
votre groupe comme avec ceux d'autres
groupes de l'arc républicain vous l'avez
souligné lors de l'examen du texte au
Sénat l'ame a été supprimé au profit
d'une aide médicale d'urgence sur ce
sujet la position de mon gouvernement
est claire l'ame est un dispositif
nécessaire nécessaire parce qu'elle
répond à un impératif de sé publ elle
permet de soigner les personnes malades
présentes sur notre sol sans passer
nécessairement par les services
d'urgence elle permet de prendre en
charge rapidement des maladies et
d'éviter leur propagation comme les
hépatites le VIH ou les infection
respiratoire j'ajoute que l'ame est un
dispositif extrêmement contrôlé c'est
même celui dont le taux de contrôle est
le plus élevé de l'assurance maladie
alors monsieur le Président Panch une
réforme de l'ame déjà été mené en 2019
elle s'était faite logiquement dans le
cadre de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale comme vous avec mon
gouvernement je cherche toujours
l'efficacité de nos politiques publiques
et je suis ouverte à des évolutions de
laame mais pour y parvenir nous avons
besoin d'un diagnostic complet et
objectif c'est l'objet de la mission
confiée par les ministres géralanin
Aurélien Rousseau et AG
à Patrick stéphanini et à claud Dvin les
conclusions de cette mission seront
rendues d'ici quelques jours elles
seront naturellement rendu public avec
les ministres nous proposerons le cas
échéant les évolutions nécessaires dans
le cadre d'un texte adapté monsieur le
président Bertrand Pancher nous sommes
déterminés à apporter des réponses
justes et efficaces aux Français cela
vaut sur laame comme sur les autres
sujets je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Ted pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'État à l'enfance madame
la ministre vous avez annoncé le
maintien de la civise avec des missions
élargies à toute forme de violence faite
aux enfants les chifres les chiffres qui
suivent sont
insupportables toutes les 3 minutes un
enfant est victime d'inceste ou de
violence
165000 enfants sont victimes d'agression
sexuelle à l'échelle d'une classe cela
représente un enfant sur 5 80 % des des
agressions sont intrafiliales et 50 %
des victimes disent ne pas avoir été
soutenu par leurs propres parents
pardonnez ma franchise mais ces chiffrs
donne envie de vomir madame la Première
ministre a lancé un plan contre les
violences envers les enfants passons
maintenant de la parole aux actes des
actes il en existe dans ma
circonscription du forê dans la Loire où
l'association Espace autour de Madame
liydy Pevel fait un travail remarquable
pour repérer des enfants victimes
d'agissement monstrueux espace a reçu
une subvention de 50000 € en 2022 que
vous avez supprimé en 2023 plongeant les
bénévoles dans un profond désarrois ma
question est simple l'association Espace
peut-elle de nouveau toucher cette
subvention pour continuer à Saver des
enfants victimes d'inceste et de
violence trs bien merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Charlotte cobel ministre en charge de
l'enfance merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Jean-Pierre tête oui je vous
remercie pour votre question vous l'avez
dit madame la Première ministre a
présenté un plan de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles à l'occasion du
comité intermissel de l'enfant
le 20 novembre dernier ce plan ambitieux
est accompagné de renforts de moyens
humains et financier pour tous les
acteurs de la lutte contre ces violences
dont vous avez rappelé les chiffres un
enfant sur 10 c'est déjà pas mal un
adulte sur 10 c'est déjà pas mal mais en
tout cas des chiffres inacceptables y
compris dans les suites qui sont données
à ces enfants un renfort des moyens à
renfort financier une campagne de
sensibilisation une plateforme 119 pro
la réécriture des programme d'éducation
à la vie affective et sexuelle le
maillage des aped il y a beaucoup de
choses dans ce plan un plan ambitieux à
la hauteur des enjeux nous l'avons dit
nous souhaitons que le travail de la
civise continue avec des modalités une
feuille de route renouvelé et centré sur
certaines missions sur les violences
sexuel nous présenterons le détail avec
Éric Dupont Moretti dans les toutes
prochaines semaines mais vous avez
rappelé la lutte contre les violances
sexuelles c'est l'affaire de tous et de
toutes y compris du secteur associatif
dont nous avons évidemment besoin vous
vous avez appelé mon attention sur
l'association Espace qui fait un travail
remarquable dans votre territoire
notamment en milieu scolaire elle a été
financé dans le cadre d'un appel à
projet en 2022 le nouveau plan violence
comprend de nouveaux financements pour
des appels à projets ambitieux nous
regardons ensemble si l'association peut
à nouveau recouvrer des sommes pour
conduire ses projets je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le député oui madame la
ministre je connais les blessures vécues
en silence par enfant loin du regard des
autres comme on dit je vis au quotidien
avec un garçon de 14 ans qui a subi
pendant des mois les violences physiques
et psychologiques de son propre père mon
but est de porter la voix de ceux que
l'on n'entend pas cette phrase et de
Madame Brigitte Macron elle a raison
nous devons porter la voix des enfants
victimes d'inceste ou de violence
n'attendez pas merci de soutenir
l'association Espace qui sauve des
enfants chaque jour merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Caroline yadan
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la
Présidente cette question s'adresse à
madame la ministre berérangerre
Couillard ministre de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes 52 jours 52
jours déjà se sont écoulés depuis ce
samedi sanglant au cours duquel s'est
ouvert un gouffre abissal dans lequel a
été aspiré notre humanité un gouffre
fait de sang de torture de mutilations
et de larmes une violence absolue
commise au nom de Allah Akbar par des
monstres armés de couteau et dépourvu de
cœur le 7 octobre dernier des
terroristes islamistes du Hamas
bibronnés à la haine des Juifs ont
pénétrer le territoire souverain
d'Israël pour commettre de telles
atrocités qu'un esprit humain du mal à
le concevoir si cette passion
exterminatrice a visé indifféremment des
hommes des personnes âgées des
adolescents des des enfants des bébés
elle a aussi ciblé spécifiquement des
femmes les associations féministes
adeptes des Mitou de l'écriture
inclusive et des hontes croix auraiit dû
condamner avec force les viols acharnés
les femmes enceintes et ventré la nudité
carbonisée les adolescentes exhibé comme
autant de macabres
trophées il n'en a pourtant rien été les
nouvelles féministes intersectionnelles
se sont
elles ont balayé d'un revers de main les
victimes de ces abominations sous le
prétexte évident de leur origine
israéliennes et juive elles ont effacé
la douleur de ces femmes suppliciées
parfois même en idolâtrant la violence
de leur bourreau devenu soudainement des
résistants ce ce féminisme à géométrie
variable pour lequel les origines
importent davantage que les faits
criminels a choisi d'exclure samedi
dernier l'accès à la marche contre les
violences fa aux femmes aux
manifestantes venu rappeler la mémoire
des femmes victimes du pogrome du 7
octobre parfois encore retenu comme
otage dans les tunnels du ramas quand on
combat les violences faites aux femmes
on les combat partout et tout le temps
Madame la Ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour garantir que les subventions
de l'état de puiss profiter qu' des
associations la parole est à Madame
Berard ministre en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes les hommes et de la
lutte contre les
discriminations merci beaucoup mes chers
collègues madame la ministre merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
yadan
ce qui s'est passé en Israël est
abominable des femmes ont été violées
ont été mutilées elles ont été torturé
le viol est une arme de guerre laissant
de nombreuses femmes et filles
psychologiquement
traumatisé souvent la violence sexuelle
n'est pas simplement perpétrée par des
soldats solitaires mais s'apparente à
une tactique de guerre
délibérée la violence sexuelle déplace
terrorise détruit des individus des
familles et des communautés entière
atteignant des niveaux de cruauté
inimaginables à l'égard de femmes de
tout âge ces horreurs qu'elles aient eu
lieu en Israël où de nombreux cas de
viol ont été rapportés le 7 octobre
dernier en Ukraine au Soudan ou dans le
reste du monde je les ai condamné et je
les condamne ici
fermement vous évoquez madame la député
tout particulièrement la manifestation
du 25 novembre pourquoi a-t-elle été
créée pour lutter contre contre les
violences faites aux femmes c'est un
combat qui est universel et je dénonce
de nouveau de nouveau ici
l'instrumentalisation qui en a été faite
madame la députée on ne trie pas les
violences en fonction des conflits des
individus ou des nationalités je
m'oppose fermement à toute forme de
récupération c'est là que la diplomatie
féministe a tout son importance tous les
conflit rappelle la nécessité de la mise
en œuvre de l'agenda femme paix sécurité
il reconnaît que la participation des
femmes au mécanisme des résolution des
crises et de stabilisation est
indispensable et un impact positif sur
la paix 104 états- membres des nations-
Unies ont déjà adopté ce plan d'action
au niveau national madame la députée
vous me posez plus particulièrement la
question des subventions aux
associations sachez que les projets
soumis à ces subventions doivent
s'inscrire pleinement dans les
orientations de mon ministère et je suis
évidemment extrêmement vigilante à ce
quees associations partagent nos valeurs
universelles et donc elles seront
soutenu que si elles partagent ses
valeurs universelles merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre la
parole est à Monsieur
emmeric Salmond pour le rassemblement
national madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre délégué en charge du renouveau
démocratique le le 29 mai 2005 le peuple
français a dit non à la ratification du
traité établissant une Constitution pour
l'Europe par ce vote clair les Français
ont dit non à cette construction à
marche forcée vers le fédéralisme mais
ont également rappelé qu'ils voulaient
avoir leur mots à dire sur la
construction européenne nous savons tous
que contre l'avis des français le traité
de Lisbonne palcopie de la Constitution
a été imposé par le président Sarkozi et
les parlementaires de l'époque réunis en
congrès la semaine dernière suite à une
proposition du groupe macroniste et de
son député verofstad deux résolutions
tendant à la révision des traités et à
la primauté du droit de l'Union
européenne sur le droit national ont été
adoptés c'est une étape de plus vers le
fédéralisme je n'ai pas le temps de
revenir sur l'ensemble des mesures
néfastes et antidémocratiques contenues
dans ces deux textes et je n'en
présenterai qu'une seule en exemple le
choix d'augmenter le nombre de domaines
dans lesquels les actions sont décidées
par un vote à la majorité qualifiée en
lieu et place de la règle de l'unanimité
garante de la souveraineté des nations
de son côté Marine Le Pen a proposé une
déclaration des droits des peuples et
des nations qui réaffirme notamment la
supériorité du droit national sur toute
institution
supranationale ma question sera donc
simple monsieur le ministre
laisserez-vous le Parlement européen
imposer au français cette excélération
vers le fédéralisme ou allez-vous donner
du sens à votre ministère du renouveau
démocratique en interrogeant les
Français sur ce sujet notamment par VO
référendaire je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Besch ministre en charge du
commerce extérieur de l'attractivité des
Français de
l'étranger merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente mesames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Salm d'abord
je voudrais excuser la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères qui
est retenu à une réunion ministérielle
de l'OTAN
oui les institutions ont évolué
en Europe depuis 1950 depuis 73 ans nous
avons eu le premier traité le traité de
Paris puis il y a eu les traité de Rome
de Luxembourg de Maastricht d'Amsterdam
de Nice ou encore de Lisbonne oui à
chaque fois l'Union européenne s'est
transformé pour faire face à des défis
qui étaient soit liés à son
élargissement soit lié à son
approfondissement ou encore au
changement de contexte notamment après
la chute du mur de Berlin la semaine
dernière le Parlement européen a proposé
effectivement une révision des traités a
cette révision sera transmise au Conseil
européen qui décidera des suites à
donner le Parlement européen est donc
parfaitement dans son rôle en proposant
une ractification une modification des
traités il appartiendra aux États
ensuite de décider et vous le savez très
bien que ça se fait à l'unanimité des
états s'il y a lieu ou pas et ensuite
dans un processus démocratique propre à
chaque état de modifier ces traités face
au contexte que nous connaissons
notamment celui du retour de la guerre
en Europe celui d'un certain nombre de
crises qui se fait au Marg de l'Union
européenne et dont il convient également
de se protéger la vraie différence
monsieur le député c'est que votre camp
depuis des années qui a sescrime à
vouloir déconstruire l'Europe à vouloir
déconstruire une Europe qui nous protège
qui protège notamment l'Union européenne
de la guerre qui nous permet de vivre la
période de paix la plus longue que nous
avons jamais connu depuis 2000 ans cette
Europe qui permet aussi de faire face
aux crises nous cette Europe nous
voulons continuer à la construire pour
protéger les Français et pour rendre la
France plus
forte merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député oui monsieur
le ministre vous n'avez toujours pas
compris les Français ils veulent une
autre Europe une Europe des nations et
pour cela vu que vous ne voulez pas
organiser de référendum vous ne voulez
pas le donn la parole ils auront une
date à retenir pour pouvoir donner leur
parole le 9 juin en votant Jordane
Bardella je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Arnaud legal pour le groupe
la France
insoumise madame la
Présidente merci ma question est à la
ministre d'affaires étrangères il y a
quelques jours 18 anciens ambassadeurs
de France ont appelé un rééquilibrage de
notre diplomatie au Orient il déplore
que la seule réponse au massacre
injustifiable commis par le Hamas soit
une guerre totale un cauchemar
humanitaire des bombardements
indiscriminés et disproportionné ayant
fait à Gaza 13000 morts civiles donc
5300 enfants il s'inquiète d'une
politique que le ministère français des
Affaires étrangères a lui-même qualifié
de terreur opéré par les colons C
jordaniie occupé avec le soutien du
gouvernement
israélien à Gaza la trêve en cour
prolongé de 48 he à ce stade a permis la
libération d'otage nous partageons not
votre immense soulagement après la
libération de trois otages mineurs
franco-israéliens mais c'est insuffisant
au regard de la souffrance des familles
cette rêve a également permis enfin la
livraison d'aide humanitaire mais c'est
insuffisant au regard des immenses
besoins le 9 novembre le président de la
République a appelé un cesser le feu la
ministre des Affaires étrangères a elle
même dit dimanche la France considère
qu'il faut une trêve qui permette
d'aboutir à un cesser le feu ces paroles
sont bienvenues mais pour qu'elles soit
entendu et suivi des faits il faut des
actes que fait la France concrètement
pour contribuer à se cesser le feu cette
étape est décisive car elle doit être la
première vers une solution politique sur
la base du droit international et en
particulier d'une solution à deux États
qui quoi qu'en disent les sceptiques n'a
jamais été tenté il faut que la
diplomatie française soit au rendez-vous
de son histoire et de la
paix je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur bech ministre en charge du
commerce extérieur de l'attractivité des
Français de l'étranger merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Le Gal permettez-moi à nouveau d'excuser
l'absence de la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères retenue à une
réunion ministérielle de l'OTAN
permettez-moi aussi de me réjouir comme
vous du retour de ces trois enfants Herz
SAR et etane néanmoins notre notre joie
est contenue puisque nous pensons
toujours aux cinq Français qui sont
portés disparus et qui probablement sont
encore aage du Hamas et sachez que nous
ne ménageons aucun effort pour les
rendre à l'affection de leur famille la
France n'abandonne aucun de ses
concitoyens la position de la France est
constante elle n'a pas évolué depuis
quasiment les débuts de la 5e République
Monsieur le Député nous avons toujours
été favoraable à une situation à deux
États qui est la seule qui permette à
deux peuple de vivre en paix et en
sécurité côte à côte nous ne ménangeons
pas les efforts de la diplomatie
française en ce moment même sur le
terrain pour faire en sorte que la trêve
humanitaire que nous appelons depuis des
semaines et qui a permis monsieur le
député la libération des otages que
cette trêve puisse être prolongée et que
cette trêve puisse déboucher sur un
cesser le feu qui lui-même permettra de
réengager le processus politique qui
permettra à deux états de vivre en paix
et en sécurité c'est tout le sens
monsieur le député de l'engagement de la
diplomatie
française je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
député je crains que cette voix ne soit
pas assez entendu car est pas suivi
d'actes fort et donc je rappelle que
j'appelle à a marché pour la paix la
justice et à in cessé le feu permanent à
l'appel de nombreuses associations ONG
syndicat partis politique ce samedi à
14h merci je vous
remercie je voudrais passer la parole à
Monsieur Bruno mulienne pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre déléguée chargée des
personnes handicapées madame la ministre
ministre pour commencer je voudrais que
notre associer notre groupe à la douleur
de la famille et des proches du jeune
Thomas que nous partageons depuis 6 ans
nous agissons pour obtenir soutenir les
professionnels du secteur du handicap la
mission d'accompagnement des
travailleurs en AAT vers des parcours
professionnels c'est ainsi
considérablement renforcé ces dernières
années le projet de loi plein emploi
voté il y a 2 semaines permettra aux
travailleurs handicapés en AAT de
bénéficier de l'essentiel des droits
individuels et collectif des salariés
par ces mesures nous offrons aux
personnes en situation de handicap la
possibilité de s'autodéterminer et
facilit-on leur recherche d'emploi en
milieu ordinaire j'ai cependant été
alerté madame la ministre notamment par
Estia 78 du fait que mon département des
Yvelines est l'un de ceux les moins bien
dotés en foyer de vie ou médicalisés
pour personnes en situation de handicap
leur inquiétude que je partage est
grande sur l'avenir des établissements
qu'il gèrre avec et vous le savez
professionnalisme m dévouements je sais
madame ministre que vous n'en doutez
absolument pas cependant en faisant
converger les droits des travailleurs
des zates vers ceux des salariés le
gouvernement fait peser sur ces
établissements le financement de ces
dispositifs qu'ils auront du mal à
supporter dans les ivelines pour les 16
établissements d'Estia 78 c'est un
déficit de près de 400000 € annuels qui
est envisagé un risque de fermeture
n'est donc pas exclure ce qui rendrait
les personnes qui travaillent sans
accompagnement et sans EMP ainsi madame
la ministre quelle solution le
gouvernement comp-il mettre en place
pour répondre à ses inquiétudes et ainsi
garantir dans les ivelines comme
ailleurs la pérennité de
l'accompagnement par le travail des
Français en situation de handicap je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Fadila
katabi ministre en charge des personnes
handicapées merci bien Madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député milienne vous
mettez effectivement le droit sur un
vrai un vrai sujet à savoir la
transformation du modèle des zat
pourquoi celle-ci est-elle nécessaire en
fait nous avons mis fin à une véritable
injustice sociale en alignant les droits
des travailleurs des zates sur ceux des
salariés grâce au projet de loi plein
emploi vous l'avez dit désormais ces
travailleurs pourront bénéficier par
exemple de la prime transport d'une
complémentaire santé ou encore d'une
prime exceptionnelle ce qui n'était pas
le cas jusqu'à présent cela bien sûr a
un impact financier sur ces
établissements c'est la raison pour
laquelle avec Olivier dus SOP nous avons
lancé une mission
IGAS igvf qui nous permettra de refonder
le système de financement tout en
continuant bien sûr de garantir la
qualité de l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de handicap au
sein bien sûr de ces établissements j'en
profite bien sûr pour saluer la qualité
du travail qui est mené par l'ensemble
des professionnels du secteur nous avons
pu encore le constater hier avec Marc F
dans le loireéchelle où nous étions en
déplacement notre gouvernement entend
les inquiétudes et agit 21 millions
d'euros ont été versés dans un premier
temp temps pardon en en partie via le
fond d'aide à la transformation des
zates en effet ces établissements
doivent se transformer en véritable
outil de monter en compétence pour
faciliter les parcours vers le milieu
ordinaire nous attendons désormais les
conclusions justement de la mission pour
pouvoir garantir leur soutenabilité
financière sur la durée vous l'aurez
compris monsieur le député nous avons
amélioré la situation sociale des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
travaillent en nat et bien nous sommes
en train de travailler sur la leur
situation financière pour faire en sorte
bien sûr que le modèle puisse être
pérennisé je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur
Guillaume Garot pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'assem
l'association UFC Que Choisir a déposé
un recours pour inaction de l'État face
à la désertification médicale qui ne
cesse d'avancer 6 millions de Français
sont 100 médecins traitants 9 millions
de Français vivent dans un désert
médical concrètement c'est votre médecin
qui part en retraite et qui n'est pas
remplacé ce sont des mois et des mois
pour avoir un rendez-vous chez le spéci
et ce sont des listes entières de
dentistes qui ne prennent plus de
patient c'est ça la réalité alors depuis
des années l'état enchaîné des mesures
d'incitation pour nos médecins avec des
chèqus à la clé pour s'installer là où
on a besoin deux peine perdu ça n'a rien
réglé ça coûte un poon de dingue comme
dirait le président de la République et
les inégalités d'accès aux soins se sont
aggravé monsieur le ministre le temps
est venu de réguler l'installation et
l'exercice médical comme ça se fait pour
les pharmaciens pour les kinés pour les
infirmières pour mieux répartir nos
forces médicales à l'échelle du
territoire national car je vous le dis
notre santé ne peut pas dépendre de
notre code
postal monsieur le ministre de la Santé
la majorité le gouvernement se refuse à
cette régulation alors ce recours de Que
Choisir bien c'est simplement
l'expression de l'incompréhension des
Français devant l'incapacité du
gouvernement à résister au corporatisme
monsieur le ministre de la Santé notre
groupe de travail transpartisan a fait
des propositions très précises sur les
déserts médicaux pour sortir des
politiques qui ne marchent pas monsieur
le ministre quand allez-vous accepter
enfin d'y travailler je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien rousau ministre de la santé et
de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
ministre
garot inaction quand le président de la
République décide dès 2018 de lever le
numérus closus et que nous et que nous
et que nous formons aujourd'hui 10000
médecins alors que nous en formions 3500
dans les années 90 inaction quand pour
permettre de recruter et de fidéliser
dans les hôpitaux la première ministre
annonce fin août l'augmentation de 25 %
du travail des professionnels de santé à
l'hôpital la nuit inaction quand 80 % de
la population de notre pays est couverte
par une communauté professionnelle
territoriale de santé inaction quand
2000 maisons de santé plury
professionnel sont installés sur le
territoire inaction encore
quand les négociations conventionnelles
avec pour premier objectif
l'attractivité et l'installation des
professionnels de santé a été posé par
le gouvernement inaction inaction quand
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale plaît que vous avez
souhaité sur lequel vous avez souhaité
censurer le gouvernement la semaine
dernière permet de d'étendre les
compétences à d'autres professionnels
médicaux pour prendre en charge la santé
de nos concitoyens il n'y a pas action
monsieur le député mais peut-être
peut-être il y a-t-il un débat sur la
cohersition la coohersition en effet
celle que vous prenez elle a été
discutée elle a été discutée à de
nombreuses reprises dans cet hémicycle
et en fait je pense qu'il ne faut pas
confondre l'inaction la détermination
qui est celle de ce gouvernement et de
cette majorité et la prestidigitation
qui est manifestement plutôt votre
orientation merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre non la parole est à Madame
Marie pochon pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre de Fran irréconciliaable un
risque de basculement une guerre civile
évitée la récupération la colère la
violence la vengeance qui fait monter la
haine alors qu'on en sait encore si peu
voilà la situation de notre pays depuis
le dramatique décès de Thomas dans le
petit village de crépole j'ai grandi
juste à côté je sais l'importance de ces
fêtes à quel point elle rythme nos vies
et je ne peux qu'imaginer l'immense
douleur et l'incompréhension de toutes
celles et ceux qui étaient présents
Thomas avait 16 ans jamais il n'aurait
dû mourir une fête de village 16 blessés
un mort pour le village de crépole et
tous ceux alentour rien ne sera plus
jamais comme avant c'est pour certains
le miroir d'une partie de la société où
l'on plante pour une moquerie ou encore
l'amorçage d'une guerre ethnique mais de
quoi parle-t-on depuis une semaine les
ratonades d'extrême droit terrorist
toute personne qui n'aurait pas la bonne
couleur de peau la bonne religion qui
n'habiterait pas le bon quartier ce qui
se répand c'est la haine des noms qu'on
jette en en pâure impunément les
représailles et la vengeance aveugle
c'est du racisme de
l'islamophobie la vérité madame la
Première ministre c'est que cette haine
qui se répand c'est l'aboutissement de
tant d'échecs et que la promesse
républicaine n'a plus de valeur parce
que vos politiques l'ont affaibli elle
n'est qu'un joli discours masquant la
fracture territoriale le sentiment
d'être toujours relégué pour toutes les
jeunesses de France
l'ordre l'ordre l'ordre peine à masquer
la jeunesse mise au pas du SNU les 493
les ministres devant la justice les bras
tendus à l'extrême droite et les manif
pour rien alors oui je sais les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui y
croient mais la promesse républicaine
n'est pas une petite promesse c'est la
garantie de notre vivre ensemble le
fondement de ce que nous sommes et à
crpol tout comme à la monnaie on a
souvent l'impression qu'elle n'est pas
faite pour nous elle devrait être votre
seu cap vous avez failli quand
allez-vous enfin prendre vos
responsabilités je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Verand
ministre en charge du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Marie pochon sincèrement en
écoutant votre question j'ai peur que
vous soyez en train de passer à côté de
quelque chose qui se passe dans notre
pays j'ai peur madame pochon que vous
n'ayez pas été à l'écoute de ce que vous
et moi avons entendu hier lorsque N
étions dans la Drome vous n'étiez pas
avec moi lorsque j'ai rencontré la les
habitants de de crépool et la famille de
Thomas et vous étiez avec moi dans cet
établissement dans ce lycée au sein
duquel vous avez eu deux peurs qui se
sont exprimées la peur de la jeunesse de
Crépol de voir les amis des assaillants
de Thomas entraîné des représailles à
leur rencontre et effectivement la peur
des habitants du quartier de la monnaie
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
assaillants sinon qu'ils portent
peut-être des patronymes ou qu'ils
habitent dans le même quartier et qui
ont peur à leur tour de de subir des
représailles de la part d'une partie des
habitants madame pochon quand on parle
quand on parle de risque de basculement
de la société évidemment ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas et ce contre quoi nous
luttons avec détermination c'est
lorsqu'il il apparaîtrait qu'il y aurait
comme de France qui se ferait face et
qui ne serait plus capable de
communiquer et quand on serait dans la
généralisation je laisse cela madame la
députée aux extrêmes je laisseela aux
extrêmes vous ne pouvez pas faire le
lien dans la question que vous posez vu
la douleur des familles vu la douleur et
la peur que nous avons ressenti dans la
drô vu la nécessité que la République
soit la hauteur et que la cohésion
nationale soit la meilleure réponse à
appter à la haine vous ne pouvez pas
faire le lien dans votre question avec
des choses telles que le 493 ou le SNU
madame la députée ce que la population
nous demande c'est de montrer que l'État
est ferme que l'autorité républicaine
est là que nous sommes capables d'agir
sur les inégalités et l'état de droit
est fort et j'étais hier avec le
procureur qui a pu répondre aux
interrogations et aux inquiétudes de la
population la justice passera jamais une
intervention aussi groupée n'a été aussi
bien réalisée dans des délais aussi
courts
on été arrêté en MOS de 3 jours les
chefs d'accusation reten par le
procureur sont passibles pour l'auteur
de l'assassinat présumé de la peine de
prison à perpétuité c'est cela que la
population a besoin d'entendre et ce
qu'a dit la première ministre tout à
l'heure et ce que dit à l'envie et à
raison monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur que nous luttons contre ces
bandes armé qui s la pagaille et la
terreur dans nos villes et dans nos
campagesci monsieur le ministre madame
la député monsieur le ministre la
promesse républicaine ça n'est pas que
l'ordre l'ordre et l'ordre je vous
remercie
la parole s'il vous plaît un peu de
calme la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
lacrress pour le groueenaissance merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Industrie ma question sur
la réindustrialisation de notre pays je
associe Guillaume casparian député de
chartre d'où vous revenez de la
célébration la semaine dernière en
présence du président de la République
d'un investissement de plus de 2
milliards d'euros d'un groupe médical
international qui montre le succès de la
politique d'attractivité
l'investissement TR France qui est
évidemment le produit de la mobilisation
des acteurs locaux cela va de soi mais
aussi la simplification administrative
la suppression de la CVAE et la
fourniture d'une énergie décarbonée bon
marché celle de notre énergie nucléaire
dont le régulateur a encore dit
récemment qu'elle pourrait être fournie
à des prix contenus par l'énergéticien
national mais vous lancez aussi la
Semaine de l'Industrie vous l'avez fait
hier qui valorisera l'enseignement
professionnel et en particulier les
lycées professionnels et le ministre des
Finances se trouvait il y a quelques
jours encore en Nouvelle-Calédonie pour
sécuriser la poursuite de la production
nickel de notre industrie automobile
européenne à tant besoin ma question
porte précisément sur la décarbonation
des 50 sites les plus émetteurs de CO2
vous avez signé en effet les 50
conventions qui détonnent les détails et
la quotité pour chaque site de l'aide
qui leur sera apporté et en particulier
dans deux axes quel sera le rythme et
l'effort qui sera consenti en
particulier pour le passage à la
biomasse des sites charbonniers je pense
à saintavolde mais aussi à la
transformation du sel à dombal et
également le deuxième axe celui de
l'hydrogène car pour décarboner la
chimie et la sidérurgie dans la veillé
de la Moselle ou celle de la Sare il
faudra des ressources considérables à la
fois pour produire l'hydrogène vert et
aussi le transporter dans cette mesure
nous attendons monsieur le ministre un
effort décisif notamment pour la
recherche y compris pour les universités
comme celle de Lorine notre industrie
lourde est devant une étape décisive
face aux doctrines de la décroissance
c'est le socle de notre prospérité merci
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Roland lescur
ministre en charge de
l'Industrie madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député laacesse merci pour votre
question la semaine dernière vous l'avez
dit nous étions à chartre ville cher au
président de la commission d'affaires
économiques avec le président de la
République pour annoncer un
investissement exceptionnel un grand
groupe danois pharmaceutique un des plus
grands au monde choisit à nouveau la
France pour investir un montant
exceptionnel ces bonnes nouvelles
n'arrivent pas par hasard vous l'avais
dit elles sont aussi le résultat de 6
ans de travail acharné de ce
gouvernement et de ses prédécesseurs
pour rendre la France attractive la
réindustrialisation doit se faire
partout chez vous en meurt et Mosel
territoire d'industrie s'il en est au
bout du monde en Nouvelle-Calédonie
aussi où le développement de la voiture
électrique donne de nouvelles
perspectives au nickel et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le maire y est ce
défi il fait face aujourd'hui à deux
écueils majeurs le premier nous aurons
besoin de ressources énergétiques la
biomasse l'hydrogène de l'électricité
décarboné vous l'avez dit et avec madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
nous aurons l'occasion de vous présenter
un plan notamment sur l'hydrogène qui
vous est cher et qui est cher à votre
territoire deuxième défi majeur celui
des talents novon nordis c'est 2000
travailleurs pour construire le chantier
et 500 emplois durables pour cette usine
qui en détient qui en occupe déjà 1600
et pour ça j'engage tous les
parlementaires de tous les bancs à
s'engager dans la Semaine de l'Industrie
qui cette semaine met en place 5500
événements partout en France qui vont
donner envie à nos jeunes hommes et à
nos jeunes femmes de rejoindre
l'industrie la réindustrialisation c'est
un combat qui doit nous rassembler qui
doit concerner tout le monde la
formation l'attractivité l'emploi la
lutte contre les discriminations tout ça
doit nous conduire à mener nos jeunes
vers l'industrie et a gagné ce combat de
toute une génération merci monsieur le
député merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Rachel K
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur il s'appelait
Thomas il avait 16 ans il a été tué le
lundi 19 novembre avant tout je voudrais
ici lui rendre hommage saluer sa mémoire
dire ma solidarité à ses proches sa
famille et tous les blessés l'extrême
droite a instrumentalisé son maître des
expéditions vengeresse ont été lancé à
roman sur iser à Lyon à grenobble et à
Rennes un seul a été franchi
qu'avez-vous faire pour protéger nos
concitoyens de ces bandes néonazis qui
menace qui agresse qui terrorise
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur l'UR
est grave quelle question posé quel mot
utiliser quel fait décrire pour enfin
vous faire réagir faut-il vous rappeler
les croix gamé tagué sur les murs de nos
villes la profanation des tombes juives
et musulmanes les ratonnades et les
meurtres racistes monsieur le ministre
nous vous allons depuis des mois sur ces
ministres privé que font les services de
renseignement expliquez-nous comment les
agresseurs de roman sur iser ont-ils eu
accès à la liste des suspects les
dissolutions judiciaires ne suffisent
pas FZ les locaux fascistes arrêtez de
SMER la confusion l'extrême droite est
antisémite islamophobe et raciste pour
nous les choses sont claires si eux la
doit être fracturée pour nous elle doit
rester unie je vais finir par un message
très fort surtout pour les jeunes nos
origines sont une richesse tenons notre
ligne si eux il div merci madame la
députée merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur
géraldanin ministre de l'Intérieur et
des
outremes
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
je pense avoir répondu à votre collègue
du groupe communiste pour dire
qu'effectivement et vous avez
parfaitement raison il faut condamner
ces milices d'extrême droite d'ultra
droite qui terrorisent et qui veulent à
la place de l'État à la place des
policiers des gendarmes dont nous
remercions le courage lutter contre ce
qu'il pensent être le grand emplacement
attaquer des noirs des Arabes par leur
couleurs de peau et non pas acceptant
l'idée que l'autorité de l'État
l'égalité républicaine c'est pouvoir
arrêter interpellé par la police de la
République selon des lois votées par le
Parlement les personnes pour ce qu'ils
font et non pas pour ce qu'ils sont vous
avez parfaitement raison et c'est pour
cela que je voudrais en premier lieu
plutôt que de les mettre en cause madame
la députée remercier les service de
renseignement qui ont déjoué 13
attentats de l'ultra droite et d'extrême
droite en France les remercier à Roman
suriser d'avoir permis en effet d'éviter
un scénario à l'irlandaise en mettant
des policiers qui ont pu interpeller une
dizaine de personnes qui sont qui ont
été présenté au service de Monsieur
gardessau et condamné quelques heures
après leurs interpellations à des Pernes
extrêmement ferme qui ont d'ailleurs été
critiqué mais qui sont l'honneur de la
justice de notre pays monsieur le
gardessau et vous dire madame la députée
que oui nous promettons les diss
solutions comme on l'a fait sur
Génération identitaire comme on l'a fait
sur une dizaine d'associations et de
groupuscules d'extrême droite mais je
regrette que vous nous ayez pas été
accompagné sur cette question puisque
votre groupe a voté contre la loi
séparatisme qui nous permet de dissoudre
association
fasciste merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Michelle
Martinez pour le rassemblement
national madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice la barbarie se
déchaîne dans notre pays et la liste des
victimes s'allonge de l'utilisation
d'armes de guerre à celle des couteaux
de cuisine cet ensauvagement n'épargne
plus aucun endroit en France que l'on
soit chez soi ou à l'école au
supermarché à la campagne ou à la ville
partout s'installe une terreur
quotidienne mais vous restez plutôt
pront à dénoncer la légitime indignation
de l'opposition que les auteurs de ces
faits nos vies sont donc plus que jamais
en surcis en témoinene les assassinats
de Thomas Lola et Enzo la mort tragique
de sokayana Fayed et d'un homme de 55
ans victime des trafics de drogue ou
encore l'agression de deux retraités il
y a de jours roise l'autorité légitime
de l'État ne fait plus peur mais rien
d'étonnant lorsque l'on sait que l'un
des agresseurs présumés de ton Tomas a
été condamné à une amende de 200 € pour
port d'armes alors que l'article L 317-8
du CSI prévoit une amende de 15000 € et
un an
d'emprisonnement vous allez sûrement me
répondre que les peines sont en hausse
mais elles restent toujours bien trop
inférieur à la montée de la violence
dans notre
société le rôle de la justice et de
uader punir et réparer or actuellement
elle ne remplit aucun des trois critères
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre je
vous le demande que comptez-vous mettre
en place afin que notre justice joue son
rôle pour que plus jamais des jeunes nai
àorté le cercueil de leur ami de 16 ans
ou que des petits enfantsent à l'hôpital
voir leurs grands-parents victime de
tentative d'assassinat je vous remercie
merci
beaucoup la parole est à
monieur des minist jtice merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Martinez en
réalité votre indescente
démagogie fait que vous n'avez pas voulu
entendre les mots du grand-père du petit
Thomas vous préférez en réalité opposer
la France rurale et tranquille
catholique et blanche à la France des
cités la France des Mohamed des
mouloudes et des Rachid
alors voyez le ministre de l'Intérieur
et votre serviteur nous faisons en sorte
que les trafiquants de drogue que les
criminels qui sont dans les cités soient
interpellés et jugés de plus en plus
sévèrement mais je pense aussi moi aux
Français à nos compatriotes aux Français
de préférence qui vivent dans nos
quartiers dans les cités et qui ne
méritent pas de lire sur les murs morts
aux Arabes nos frères juifs ont peur nos
Frères musulmans ont peur aussi vos
propos sont incendiaires et ils amènent
dans la rue les militants de l'ultr
drroite qui sont bien plus proches de
vous que de moi pour être crédible
faites le ménage chassez de vos rangs
les gudards les Identitaires les nazion
les racistes les antisémites qui sont en
réalité planqué dans vos officines
économiques et qui viennent sévèrement
d'être condamné par la cour d'appel de
Paris mais les Français ne sont pas
dupes vous ne réussirez pas votre
entreprise malsine les Français savent
que le général houfkir que manouquian ne
s'appelait ni Bernard ni Marcel vous
êtes le miroir inversé de l'extrême
gauche en réalité voyez-vous eux ils
nous font croire que nous détestons les
musulmans et vous qui n'êtes plus là
vous faites croire que les blancs sont
menacés personne n merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Justine
Gruet pour les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
républicains allez-y mes chers collègues
il y a pas de micro
merci c'est bon merci madame la
Présidente je pense que ma question
aurait pu intéresser les députés du
rassemblement national madame la
Première ministre ces derniers jours des
milliers de nos concitoyens ont été
destinataires d'un avis de taxe
d'habitation recevoir un courrier de
l'administration fiscale n'a rien
d'étonnant me direz-vous ce qu' l' est
plus c'est que des enfants en a été
destinataires comment en est-on arrivé à
cette situation ubuesque et bien parce
que l'administration a décidé de tout
automatisé en confiant la gestion des
impôts locaux à la plateforme gérer mes
biens immobiliers les contribuables
auraient donc commis des erreurs en
renseignant leurs données or il ne
s'agit pas là d'un simple bug
informatique qui aurait généré des
erreurs à la marge mais bien d'un
problème plus profond et plus grave
révélateur d'une dérive
d'hypercentralisation déconnectée de
tout bon sens oui les Français font face
à de vraies difficultés dans leurs
démarche que l'administ ration
entretient et amplifie notre pays
détient le bien triste record du niveau
d'impôts de taxes et de cotisation le
plus élevé d'Europe et pourtant nos
services publics sont de moins en moins
efficients de moins en moins présents
dans nos territoires nos compatriotes
n'ont plus d'interlocuteurs en face
d'eux et malgré leur bonne volonté ce ne
sont pas les agents des maisons France
servic qui seront en capacité de tout
régler on voit aujourd'hui le résultat
de la renationalisation de la taxe
d'habitation qui en perdant son
caractère d'impôt local a perdu
l'efficacité de nos territoires qui
maîtrisait parfaitement le
sujet madame la Première ministre ma
question est la suivante quand
allons-nous enfin en finir avec cette
technocratie qui se pose en nouvelle
classe dirigeante prenant des décisions
déconnectées de la réalité de nos
concitoyens et aboutissant à des
situations surréalistes le pouvoir
décisionnel de l'administration fait
reculer celui de nos élus de terrain
êtes-vous prêt à redonner à chaque
chacun son rôle et du sens dans leur
mission respectiv merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre en charge des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du
tourisme merci madame la présidente
madame la députée grué je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence de Bruno Le Maire
qui est en
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais vous mais je
suis
là et je me permets de vous apporter une
réponse effectivement et très clairement
Bruno Le Maire l'a dit ainsi la semaine
passée il s'agit pas d'un bug de la
plateforme gérer mes biens immobiliers
mais bel et bien d'une erreur dans un
processus qu'on peut qualifier
d'industriel je rappelle quand même 39
millions de foyers fiscaux 24 millions
de propriétaires 4 millions d'avis de
taxes d'habitation sur les résidence
secondairire est misis chaque année je
je me permets quand je dis il ne s'agit
pas d'un bug de la plateforme c'est que
ça n'est pas une erreur sur laquelle on
peut se défausser en disant la machine a
mal gérer c'est l'humain et le processus
derrière et c'est donc entièrement notre
faute j'avais à cœur de le préciser
chaque année nous avons entre 250 et
440000 contestation sur la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires lié en large majorité à des
changements d'adresse qui nous ont pas
été signal et c'est encore la raison
principale des avis envoyés à tort cette
année par exemple des locataires qui
nous ont pas signalé leur changement
d'adresse sur leur déclaration
automatique de revenu mais leur
propriétaire oui résultat on a deux
adresses pour une même personne donc
émission d'une THS ça touche souvent les
plus jeunes qui déménagent souvent il
convient d'insister sur la nécessité de
vérifier et de modifier son adresse même
sur les déclarations automatiques Bruno
Le Maire a précisé aussi que la
correction serait automatique qu'en un
mot il n'y avait rien à faire si la
répon éventuellement intéresse certains
députés Bruno Le Maire pour terminer a
donc rappelé que la direction générale
des finances publiques est en train de
résoudre ces erreurs et qu'ell s'en
excuse et nous sommes en train de les
corriger merci pour votre question et je
le répète il n'y a rien à faire pour la
correction elle est automatique merci
merci beaucoup madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur René Pilato pour
le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur daranin vos
services ont-ils peur du contrôle
citoyen sur les
élections gravé auparavant dans le Code
électoral l'annexion des listes de
procuration au procès verbaux de chaque
vote est supprimé par le décret du 11
mars
2021 celui du 22 décembre confirme que
ces listes restent en mairie enfin la
circulaire du 31 décembre à 4 mois de la
présidentielle et 5 mois des
législatives ordonne au maire de ne plus
annexer ses listes au PV cet
enchaînement méticuleux rend
techniquement impossible la vérification
d'un scrutin car la préfecture n'est
plus le lieu centralisateur en 10 jours
délai imparti pour faire un recours
prendre rendez-vous dans les 22 mairies
de ma circonscription est quasi
impossible pour celle composé de
centaines de communes cela relève du
miracle une capacité somte peu commune
chez les
candidats le matériel peut toujours être
rapatrié au Conseil constitutionnel sur
demande d'un avocat qu'il s'agit de
payer 3000 € pour y faire ce qui se
faisait gratuitement en préfecture
ensuite venir consulter le tout à Paris
et ce en une demi-journée une gageure
monsieur Darmanin pourtant nous l'avons
fait par ma circonscription de
charante sur 134 procurations
manuscrites 64 n'existait pas le
résultat s'étant joué à 24 voix cela
laisse pour le moins perplexe monsieur
le ministre des personnes malhonnêtes en
non profité pour tricher triche en
charante erreur de bulletin dans les
bureaux de la riège profession de fois
non distribué un peu partout bref
comment comptez-vous corriger le tir aux
élections européennes de juin afin
d'éradiquer ces pratiques qui abîment un
peu plus notre Démocr merci la parole
est à Gérald armanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
[Applaudissements]
outremes merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député permettez-moi d'abord
de dire que je n'ai pas tout à fait
compris votre question parce que s'il y
a 64 erreurs de procuration et que vous
avez gagné à 24 voix je me pose du coup
la la question de la la la présence dans
l'hémicycle bon mais cependant la
question que vous posez c'est celle de
d'accès d'accès aux documents d'accès
d'accès aux documents électoraux qui
sont effectivement lorsqu'on peut les
vérifier la la la la preuve que le
scrutin s'est passé dans de bonne
possibilité et de pouvoir contester le
cas échéant d'abord votre question
monsieur le député si je peux me
permettre un peu étonnant vous ne faites
pas manifestement confiance au maire de
votre circonscription puisque c'est bien
sur la base de la mairie sur la base de
la mairie monsieur le
député que non seulement on tient des
listes électorales mais qu'on les garde
par de verois pour pouvoir permettre au
48h la possibilité de vérification je ne
saurais trop vous recommettre de d'avoir
confiance dans les maires de votre
circonscription et par ailleurs qui
agissent non pas en tant qu'élu mais qui
agissent en tant que représentant de
l'État deuxièmement vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'être tout seul le celui qui va
voir les listes électorales vous pouvez
évidemment délégué des personnes c'est
tout à fait possible et c'est moins
complexe que lorsqu'il fallait aller en
moins de 48 he au centre-ville de la
préfecture parce qu'effectivement là les
choses étaient parfois différentes où on
se bataillait pour récupérer chacun l'
vécu sans doute ses sujets électoraux en
moins de 48 he troisièmement vous pouvez
toujours photographier ces listes
électorales quatrièmement vous avez tout
à fait le droit en effet de pouvoir en
demander une ampliation ces documents
ces documents monsieur le député ont
tous été validés par le Conseil d'État
qui juge de l'élection merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur lional Vibert pour le groupe
Renaissance vous m'entendez oui merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur aujourd'hui devant vous je
souhaite rendre hommage à Alan ce jeune
ardenis de 17 ans qui a fait preuve d'un
courage exceptionnel lors de l'attaque
au couteau en Irlande la semaine
passée en effet le 17 novembre dernier
Alan élève de Terminale au lycée des
métiers de baseille en stage dans un
restaurant de Dublin a été témoin d'une
violente attaque à l'arme blanche aidé
d'un livreur brésilien alan est parvenu
à désarmer l'agresseur se blessant alors
assez légèrement au mains et au visage
au cours de cette attaque cet homme a
ainsi poignardé C personnes dont trois
enfants l'un des trois enfants et une
enseignante ont d'ailleurs été
grièvement blessés armé de son courage
et au péril de sa propre sécurité
l'intervention d'Alan a probablement
permis d'éviter le pire à n'en pas
douter alan est un est un
héros siôt les
événements le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Atal ont
appelé le jeune lycéen pour le remercier
au nom de la
député des ardenes il était pour moi une
évidence de citer devant vous ce jour le
courage et le sansfroid exceptionnel
dont Alan a fait preuve et lui témoigné
la reconnaissance de la représentation
nationale ici réunie Nelson Mandela
disait le courage n'est pas l'absence de
peur mais la capacité de vaincre ce qui
fait peur à n' pas doutter Alan a vaincu
sa peur pour réaliser cet acte de
bravoure al star de Mamoudou Gassama ce
jeune Malien de 22 ans qui en 2018 a
sauvé un enfant de 4 ans suspendu dans
le vide en escaladant la façade d'un
immeuble parisien ou encore de ces
quatre élèves du lycée MAOL de perpignon
qui le 30 mars 2023 ont sauvé de la
noyade une mère et son jeune fils nous
pouvons être fiers de cette jeunesse
courageuse responsable et solidaire
merci beaucoup mon chers collègue merci
beaucoup votre temps est écoulé
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Sabrina agesti Rouach ministre en charge
de la citoyenneté et de la ville merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Vubert merci infiniment pour votre
question donc vous m'interrogez je suis
très heureuse de cette question sur
l'intervention de ce jeune Français
élève de terminale dans votre magnifique
département des Ardennes par son courage
Alan a permis et permettez-moi juste
aussi de de rapper a permis d'arrêter un
homme dangereusement armé à Dublin il y
a quelques jours vous l'avez rappelé le
président de la République et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse ont pu lui témoigner la
sincère reconnaissance de la patrie pour
son courage et je vous remercie de me
donner l'occasion de saluer à mon tour
et au nom du gouvernement son action
héroïque elle fait l'honneur de la
République face à une situation critique
Alan avec son jeune âge a démonter une
détermination sans égal agissant avec
calme et altruisme cet acte de bravoure
nous appelle notre chance d'avoir une
jeunesse engagée une jeunesse qui
n'hésite pas à prendre des risques au
nom des principes de solidarité à
travers Alan c'est cette jeunesse
courageuse que je souhaite saluer et
mettre en avant aujourd'hui comme
d'autres jeunes avant lui Alan incarne
l'engagement républicain c'est à ce
titre que je souhaite le rencontrer
prochainement au ministère de
l'intérieur avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur et vous-même et tous les
parlementaires qui voudront bien se
joindre à nous pour lui rendre
hommage le ministre de l'Intérieur a
déjà prévu de le décorer et moi je vous
propose chose un certain nombre de
médailles existe dans notre pays et je
souhaite que nous puissions travailler
ensemble avec les deux chambres
travailler à la création d'une
distinction spécifique pour notre
jeunesse pour saluer pour mettre en
valeur les valeurs de la citoyenneté
puisque je suis en charge de ce
magnifique sujet les valeurs de la
République et nos valeurs universalistes
et donc je j'ai envoyé l'invitation dans
l'émicycle et je vous attends donc au
ministère de l'Intérieur je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame les
ministr sé au gouvernement est terminée
la séance est
suspendue